حزمه عشيره من العقوبات ستخضع لها روسيا
قيود الاتحاد الاوروبي ترمي الى سد
الثغرات في التدابير المتخذه وفق لوائح
العقوبات السابقه بحسب رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
تشمل العقوبات بندا يتعلق بمحاولات
التحايل من قبل بعض الدول ما يعني ان دول
حليفه لروسيا يحتمل ان تشملها بعض
الاجراءات العقابيه وفقه هذا البنك
عبر البحر الاسود وصلت الى ثلاثه ملايين
و800,000 برميل يوميا وهو اعلى مستوى منذ
لساني ابريل عام 2022 فاعتبر الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا مؤشرا على ثغرات في حزمه
العقوبات السابقه والتي شملت تجميد اصول
البنك المركزي لمنعه من استخدام احتياطه
من النقد الاجنبي البالغي 630 مليار دولار
عزه البنوك الروسيه الرئيسيه عن نظام
المراسله الماليه الدوليه سويفت الامر
الذي سيؤخر الدفعات لروسيا مقابل
الصادراتها من النفط والغاز وحضر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول غربيه واردات النفط ثم خفضت
اوروبا اعتمادها على الغاز وجمدت المانيا
خططتها لافتتاح خط انابيب الرئيسيه للغاز
الروسي شملت العقوبات ايضا افرادا من رجال
الاعمال الروس ومقربين من الكرملين واعضاء
في الحكومه
وافراد عائلتهم مع تجميد الاصول الماليه
للرئيس بوتين وزير خارجيته في كل من
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
والمملكه المتحده وكندا اضافه لحظر
الصادرات ذات الاستخدام المزدوج وهي سلع
لها استخدامات المدنيه وعسكريه كقطاع
الغيار من قبل الغرب نعكست العقوبات على
روسيا وعلى العالم في الداخل الروسي يكون
اثر منع المصارف من استخدام سويفت الاكثر
وضوحا وبدات عائدات النفط والغازي تتدنى
بعد فرض سقوف شعريه وانخفاض عدد الزبائن
اضافه لانخفاض الوافدين الى روسيا
والمسافرين منها بسبب الحظر على الرحلات
الجويه في المجال الجوي لدول الغربي ما
يمكنه ايضا ان يؤدي الى ايقاف جزء كبير من
اسطول الطيران الروسي اما التداعيات
عالميا فاختارها توسع معدلات الجوع خاصه
في دول الافريقيه وارتفاع حد في اسعار
السلع الغذائيه وفواتير الطاقه
وتقطع سلاسل الانبات
[موسيقى]